Okay, let's cooperate. It's good. It's good. You're the kind of person who
understands what I'm talking about. Let's
break this chain down quickly. Please break it off.
Well, don't be hasty. Before you release it,
cut off this neck that turns red like a stain. It's serious.
[Music] That's a
bad thing.
If you refuse to excuse me, there's no such thing as that. I'm going to
put my neck on it. It's just gone around my neck. It's
not like I'm crying in a good voice, and I'm getting fired up.  I
've made it, I'm just a little bit more
patient. It hurts. I put a stick in this hole. It's a little
tight. But I
made a grave mistake. I
thought the only mistake I made was scouting the enemy.
In fact, because of that moment, I was made
unable to return to the demon world
[MUSIC] [
MUSIC] I
can't see the future anymore [MUSIC]